[Music]
joshua's in denver hey joshua what's up
hey dave thanks for taking my call i'm a
huge fan it's an honor to speak with you
today you too how can we help
um okay so um i had a car loan in 2017
it was repossessed almost immediately
because i couldn't afford it um my
credit report says that a little over 7
500 was charged off in 2019 uh finally
got them on my debt snowball and when i
called they said that they wrote it off
for just over 4 500 and that'll get a
1099 in the mail this february
um the man from wells fargo said that i
don't owe them the debt does the 1099
actually replace the debt or should i be
on the lookout for the other 3000
popping up somewhere 10.99 hasn't got
anything to do with anything
that's just a collector technique
okay debt that is uh forgiven
is taxable and you're supposed to get a
1099 on it is he saying they are
forgiving the debt if he's saying that
he needs to send you a note that says
that
um he says that i no longer owe wells
fargo that's great send me a note that
says that did they sell the debt to
someone else
um no i asked them where the debt was um
if they did he's not telling me i asked
him where the debt was he said the only
thing that i'll get is a 1099 with the
45-27 total on it and um
there as far as wells fargo knows that i
don't know within the debt yeah
well that's
that's absolute hogwash okay okay um it
sounded like it well you're probably
just dealing with a lazy guy on the
other end of the phone now here's what's
happened okay a company can write a debt
off
meaning they give up on collecting it
and they write the bad debt off as a
business expense
at which point they can send you a 1099.
that is a tax
thing
they know they they want to write it off
as a bad debt and take the taxes take
the deduction on the taxes for the bad
debt and they want to send you the 10.99
which means you owe taxes on four
thousand five hundred dollars and that
is all proper and correct that has
nothing to do with whether you still owe
the debt
okay
if they want to forgive the debt
i want them to send me a letter or an
email at least saying
that this account has a zero balance
nothing is owed
so that some [ __ ] later they because
what they'll do is wells fargo is
classically incompetent
they're massive company
and they are full of fools
just full they packed the whole bank
full of them
okay and you got a hold of one of them
so what they'll do is they'll batch all
these bad debts on these repo uh repo
deficits in a package and they'll sell
them to a debt buyer for pennies on the
dollar who will then come and try to
collect from you
and you will go oh no they said i didn't
know it and they say oh well you do owe
it because you don't have any proof in
writing that you don't know it you had
an idiot and a cubicle on the phone tell
you that
you got to get them back on the phone
and get it in writing and you've got to
hound them until you get it in writing
if they send it to you in writing i
don't care if it's an email
that this account has been completely
written off you owe nothing we've given
up you have a zero balance
there will be no forward collection
attempts
whatever it says along those lines
settled in full whatever forgiven in
full i don't care what they call it but
something along that language you
following me
got it um so i i get that in writing and
then pay the taxes and then it's done
yep
okay awesome but i doubt that's going to
happen
because i think they still have sold
this bad debt to somebody for a nickel
on the dollar who's going to show up on
your doorstep wanting the dadgum money
for the whole thing by the way
but the 10 because the 1099 is not a
legal release from the debt
it's simply them saying we want to write
this off as a bad business expense and
we're going to put the taxes over on you
that's all it is a tax move
and generally speaking it's also a
collector's move
but yeah you're dealing with wells fargo
god help you
this is the ramsey show